hello guys greg alba is here with Jason
Horton Jason Horton comedian who you've
seen all over the interwebs
we caught a special screening of a film
I very much have been anticipated very
special very special called la-la-land
[ __ ] love this so I was 35 40 minutes
in into this and I was like best movie
of 2015 the opening scene I mean I
really don't want to give anything above
the subscribers and the people that
watch my videos are based in the US I
have the IDB pull up here so I can just
tell you this simple log line of this a
jazz pianist falls for an aspiring
actress in Los Angeles honestly it's a
simple plot he's so much so much more
it's a musical but a very different kind
of musical it stars Emma Stone and Ryan
Ryan Gosling and as you guys know I'm a
huge Ryan Gosling fan already he looks
good in a suit he looks amazing
and we look better better yeah more like
crying dogs oh yeah yeah just provides
that he's gonna go see us ah if you are
I wrote a rap song about you that's on
this channel so check it out so watch
that yeah this movies done by Damien
Chazelle who did and whiplash and wrote
the script for 10 Cloverfield Lane as
well while the impressed Wow nothing
like those other movies really no no I
mean other than a whiplash does have its
own musical scent you saw with yeah yeah
so it has its own musical sense to it
but this is like a straight-up this is a
musical yeah a little surreal definitely
its modern-day
but it has a lot of homage to like the
1950's 1940s era of Hollywood what I
loved about the musical choice was it
seemed like it's called lala land and
then you realized early on that title is
perfect yeah cuz the the musical
breakout scenes are earned like
connection to them escaping from reality
going into their imagination living in a
in a world but it's not like one of
those movies where you're like you're
just living in the head it's like Los
Angeles Los Angeles Lion
yeah yeah la-la-land yeah oh I didn't
even put it together brilliant really
and play on words I didn't even make the
connection that I saw this trailer a few
months ago that this was mad movie and
then when I was watching I was like oh I
couldn't wait to see that yeah the few
things that everyone says right away is
the cinematography looks amazing and
yeah absolutely
the way they play with lighting and the
way they play with the this the way
everything structured the storyboards
very stylistic but engrossing it's not
like you're watching some guy just play
with his toys you're watching a guy
who's really carefully crafting a
masterpiece together or it like it
really adds to the experience of it it's
not just like oh this is cool to look at
its engrossing and it really tugs up the
heart it is like a no monster motion
picture and jazz music at the same time
it really is a moving picture you know
movies are moving pictures you know we
just left Los Angeles yeah we're here in
Zurich like I was like I miss LA a
little yeah and I'd be like miss it yeah
it made me appreciate LA even more
because when you live in LA it's easy to
get caught up in how we're kind of like
dirty you can feel and yeah okay key the
you know Hollywood can sort of feel it's
so easy a little bit yeah but it does it
does bring you back to that vibe of like
there is a beauty to it magic yeah yeah
there is a magic to it so yeah and the
musical numbers are fantastic personally
I'm not the biggest musical guy I don't
really go out of my way you don't have
to be anything I really don't think you
do it doesn't feel like you're watching
a musical because the music numbers are
so like pertinent and they relate so
much to the characters that it's just a
part of the scene it's just a part of
the dialogue that you find yourself
having a big smile on your face the
first number that Ryan Gosling Ryan
Gosling sings in this movie he sings in
it and he does really him playing the
piano then the first number that they
have together is so magical like that
chemistry that we saw in Crazy Stupid
Love it's even the million times were
amplified here in this relationship that
they develop just saying all the right I
mean that's what movies are the saying
the right things at the right time but I
feel like it's not it's not forced
I really feel like they're having a
conversation as crazy magical is
and it's it's weird cuz this film could
have easily fallen under cliche
territory but it never does it is a
magical experience Emma Stone blew me
away she's fantastic about like I was
saying like she's not like like a super
like traditional hot sexy
never but she's but you said relatable
and they use that to her like to her
character yeah there's a scene was just
having like a breakdown where she's
talking about like she goes to auditions
and someone was like either prettier
than her or looks like her but is you
know a better-looking version of her and
stuff and I know you know like we know
plenty of actresses back in LA and yeah
it is just like that I've been where you
go to an audition room and like everyone
looks the same but her performance in it
was like I was expecting Ryan Gosling to
kick ass as always and he does he is
fantastic in this film he gets to show
off even have more set of skills and
before I saw this movie I read one
review somewhere else because it doesn't
come out of the States Lloyd December
but I read one review somewhere else
where they said Ryan Gosling's role
could've been play by almost any other
guy he really made it his own own unique
touch no one else in Hollywood has that
chemistry with Emma Stone like he does
alright I can read also that I think
Myles originally miles teller and Emma
Watson elique after watch nuke was I go
and I've yeah it all up and for some
reason they drop they dropped out for
whatever reason I'm really glad they got
these two to do it not that I'm saying
Emma Watson a miles teller would have
been bad yeah but the way this film came
out is just it's perfect
perfect it is hands-down the best engine
Ryan Gosling has started two of the best
movies of this year yeah and by far by
like there is and he's Darrin will be
like completely different yeah you still
get Ryan Gosling in both but you have
two different versions because Ryan
Gosling is not the kind of actor who
usually like changes up his voice yeah
but he does change up like his demeanor
he does change up at the emotional state
of the character like it's more it
reminds me of more old-school actors
like Pacino and De Niro where maybe they
didn't like change their voice all the
time or change the way they walk in the
shade all the time but they're still
playing a completely different kind of
person and you really do get that here
too and he's lovable he's funny in it
relatable - right darlings ha that's the
crazy thing about Gosling is like that's
why I think women and men love Ryan gosh
yeah because he is what is he's so cool
he's not he doesn't overplay his charm
which makes him even more charming yeah
because he he doesn't force charisma at
all in any performance he just he
understands the genre well same thing
with Emma Stone Emma Stone owns this
movie night I really do believe she
deserves an Oscar nomination for this
film she is real I mean ladies that we
love Ryan Gosling but Emma Stone really
means like her movies yeah I upped my
Emma Stone ante yeah I really felt like
he was more of the supporting role in
this film which is fine because it made
sense in the context movie yeah and one
thing I really liked about it too was
yeah this is a love story but it's more
than just that because you really do get
to individual source you know one story
about an actress and another story about
a guy who's obsessed with traditional
jazz and he feels like it's dying in
this era rather than going down cliched
territories or having cliche results in
the end it manages to make to bring big
smiles to your face at the same time you
might find yourself tearing up we were
with someone who was like crying until
the credits were doing actually she was
crying even weirder standing outside the
theatre and then she had to go and watch
it I think it's a very very moving piece
it's it's funny like I love comedy it's
entertaining
yeah even if you know it doesn't it's
not like oh yeah you know it's a little
bit funny but it's really a musical no
it's funny on a standalone level to
which I really appreciate
no sacrifice of a comedy cuz it's kind
of real it's got a real heart in it it's
real whose real charm like I was
actually thinking about seeing when it
was screening again this week I'm seeing
it again I know I'm gonna see the game
when it comes out definitely definitely
my gonna see it again this weekend I
don't know cuz we didn't even mention
what the Zurich Film Festival yeah
they're in my hotel room yeah we're at
his hotel everything of the bigger hotel
room yeah but it just seemed easier to
walk across the hall for some reason
yeah yeah I can't stop thinking I can't
wait for you to experience watching it
for the first America jealous is
something that's like oh you get to
experiences for the first it's the kind
of movie you want to take people to
watch it can be
to live vicariously through them and
you'll pay for everyone you'll send
every well yeah it right yeah yeah right
okay anyone who watches this video I'm
gonna pay for your ticket yeah sorry I
mean that promise knows it's okay yeah
[ __ ] happens man
yeah and the dance choreography music
numbers are amazing like there's it's
very much
Omar style like that like the what movie
ninja Rogers Fred Astaire yes yes
absolutely that's the PERT you nailed it
yes and specially that oh go on
Wikipedia look them up yeah I'm
wondering who those people yeah I barely
know you don't mind I know you don't
have to though yeah you just watching
the dance numbers and you just can't
help but smile at how like great the
magic is in there the music is amazing
some of it is not you know completely
original but a lot of it is original
like the song you hear and a lot of the
trailers um that's like now when I hear
like we watched the trailer before
filming this yeah and now you hear that
song just like it's your heart yeah like
it's such a meaningful song I think that
song should win like best that's the
real song at the oz bike this is an
Oscar contender for sure I'm not a big
Oscar kind of guy Academy Awards
anything but this is one of those songs
for like I'm really hoping this gets
huge
Oscar recognition because it deserves it
it's a masterpiece of my opinion I would
say though like you know I do a lot of
dating stuff on my channel and whatever
browse like if you want to take a date
to this movie I think this is a really
great movie
oh yeah I'm glad you're gonna be
hopefully hooking up a movie yeah oh
good this is the one but you gotta wait
till December yeah and this pg-13 as
well and yeah it's a good day move it's
good family movie anyone Coco by
yourself you could go by anyone can
watch it anyone um yeah Damien Chazelle
like if you thought whiplash was great
there's still more specific kind of
audience it's an r-rated film it's a
much darker the more intense and that's
yeah definitely this photo has a whole
different kind of tone a whole different
kind of emotion and you know like I'm
trying to come up with criticisms to
this and I I can't help but say it's
it's like me the second I kind of it
slows down a little bit because there's
but if it has to it has to yeah you know
it would be a movie
yeah because like the first half you
just you just have a big smile on your
face you just can't help but like have
this like gentle smile yeah I'm really
enjoying this yeah but then you know of
course a film like a real film is gonna
go through some dramatic
territory so what's going there it does
start feeling a little slower sure
beyond but you need it in order for the
other emotional impact to be there and
for the love to still be resident there
so yeah I thought this was a masterpiece
um if I make up a rating okay great good
time I do it okay I'll give you a
consensus yeah I got high from getting
Emma stoned off this movie Oh
boom boom bump 250 Jason how about uh
man I was crying for Ryan Gosling so
yeah go watch the movie when it goes out
when it when it actually comes out I
will be doing a spoiler review maybe
Jason I will still be friends in
California yeah maybe maybe I mean just
a lot of magic in Zurich - so who knows
why it's like yeah I want to learn how
to whistle yeah I know learn how to
whistle and we're cool Ryan also has a
nice voice yeah he's got a nice
everything yeah guys thanks for tuning
in you can subscribe to the real rejects
you go check out Jason Horton on
youtube.com slash Jason Horton he does a
lot of sketch comedy
he's collabed on a lot of other channels
even Laura Francesco who's been on this
channel as well so Jason was all over
the web you can follow him on our social
media as well I'll be in the description
box thank you for tuning in it's gonna
be a little bit more videos coming from
Zurich maybe some blogs who knows
I just wanted to release this first
catch you later alligator crying for
Ryan doesn't mean some like catchphrases
yeah like catchphrases do well on
YouTube yeah catchphrase